mike nobody black is surprised right now
but it still hurts nonetheless
it still stings no matter how much you
prepare yourself for the
eventuality based on experience based on
time
and time again um
this country proving this country and
its systems
proving and showing that our lives don't
matter
to them um
still a gut punch and
when i watched the proceedings in the
announcement that
one of the three officers involved in
the killing of brianna taylor
back in march was charged with
three counts of wanton endangerment in
the first degree a fourth degree felony
punishable by
up to five years in prison although
prison is not mandatory
the thing that struck me is not only
in in the initial proceeding
not only did they not say her name
they didn't so much as say her initials
that the charge had nothing to do with
her death
it was about wanting endangerment for
shooting into other surrounding
apartments
it completely ignored her death so this
was in some ways
more insulting in a weird way more
insulting than just a simple hey we
didn't find any reason
to bring charges against these officers
it's like oh yeah they did something
wrong but it had nothing to do with
brianna taylor
otherwise they were doing their job
and i get so sick and tired mike of of
when police shootings happen
and police inevitably get off going back
to
quoting w.e.b du bois that a system
cannot fail those
who was never designed to protect i
guess so sick and tired of going back to
that
and i'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired as i know you are
it wasn't a surprise man but it hurt
nonetheless when they first
when the proceedings were going on i'm
like are they talking about a different
case did they go do they cut to this too
early
is this some other court proceedings
that we were in on and not brianna
taylor because there was no mention of
this 26 year old
first responders life who ironically
sadly and tragically
received no aid at the time of her death
michael right
mike i'm not going to be long on it i'm
not going to be long on it because of
what you said there's a
deep sadness and
you know there are many black americans
who uh
who deal with the sadness and they cover
it up and cover it up and so that's
that's part of the reason
some people are able to go day to day
because they compartmentalize
or they repress some very raw feelings
and some raw realities that are part of
our society today so
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna talk about
it long because i really i don't even
know how i'm gonna react on the air to
tell you the truth i'm just being 100
honest with you
um yeah not a surprise not a surprise
and i think we got to get beyond the
point mike of
of trying to uh of wagging our fingers
at people or explaining the situation
the situation is clear
yeah it's clear and it was it was clear
long before
you took your first breath and long
before i took mine
you know whether it was frederick
douglass talking about it years ago or
james baldwin with the fire next time i
think on and on
there have been songs have been poems
there have been sermons uh there have
been protests
so i think we all should pretty much get
it that's not that's not where i'm going
with this i think uh
it really is a matter of conscience it's
a matter of humanity
and i know one of the slogans is we're
done dying
since we're done dying i think it is a
it's a time of dismantling
some of the laws that exist that protect
those who who really should not be
protected those who have not
done their jobs with conscience done
their jobs with integrity and principle
it is time to dismantle some of those
laws kentucky has them many states have
them
if you go and you investigate them you
say well that's not just
that's not fair that's not how a
democracy works and so until we start
looking at it
beyond uh just a a isolated incident or
you know
it's just it just happened this time it
was just a coincidence
or whatever no until we start looking at
it deeply
i'm going to continue to be in this
situation let me tell you one thing i'll
tell you one thing
uh just being completely honest i used
to live
uh i i used to live in an area it's
pretty affluent area
um the diversity was the diversity in
the area was
well we got the hollies yeah like
we were the you know what i'm saying we
were the diversity okay
so in this school district i remember
you know you have these coffees with the
principal
so you have these coffees with the
principal and everybody talks about
their concerns
and i remember this is right after tamir
rice
was shot in cleveland uh on a playground
with with a gun that was out they had a
gun it was a report he had a gun kid had
a gun at the park and the gun was not
real
uh inexperienced officer comes in there
just shooting
and takes this life so i'm at this
coffee with the principal
in a different neighborhood and i'm
thinking
what i'm hearing right now does not
match up
with what's going on in other parts of
the country i remember one parent
breaking down in tears you know why she
was breaking down mike
i mean this would be this would be
comical if it weren't so
sad and true she was breaking down
because she wanted to know
if the gluten-free options would be in
the cafeteria this year like they were
last year she didn't see the gluten-free
options
and you know that was like the big
scandal and i was thinking
what would happen in this community
if a child was on a playground and got
shot by a police officer and killed
that community would go crazy they would
go quick they wouldn't stand for it
this same community they talk about
gluten-free stuff
and there's a loss of life they take it
seriously we're not taken
seriously enough as you said off the top
we're not taking we're not valued
enough and that's where we are and until
we address that
it's it's kind of like where are we
going we're not really having an
honest conversation well i said this
before
you know my humanity your humanity the
people that look like us
our humanity is not a conversation it's
not up for discussion it's not a debate
there are no two sides
to whether or not we deserve to be
treated you know like human beings
deserve to have the same rights and
privileges as everybody else but
you know going back to tamir rice you
know the old saying in america a black
man is a boy
and a black boy is a man and what
bothers me about
the job that these officers are doing
this this this
these charges of wanton endangerment in
the first degree
these joke charges brought forth by the
grand jury and delivered
by attorney general daniel cameron you
know mitch mcconnell's
pet i mean i'm sorry protege um
you know it all it does is condone
and confirm that these officers did
their job
like when it says to protect and serve
it should have a parenthetical that says
but not black people
you know um it's they're saying it's
legal and it's always legal it's always
justifiable it's always
rational it's always understandable yeah
yeah for all officers to fear for their
lives
when in contact with black people armed
or unarmed
that that narrative that story that that
that line of thinking it always plays
i feared for my life he or she resisted
resisted he or she disrespected us
or i didn't like the tone of voice or i
didn't like you know what it didn't hold
they didn't hold their hands in the
proper position they didn't follow
instructions
we've seen the alternative happen time
and time again with white people taken
alive when they are clearly threats
to the officers and those around around
them so add sleeping in your apartment
it was already on the list
but that's sleeping in your apartment
yeah to the long list of things that we
just can't do as black people in this
country freely
i mean what would you do what would you
do if somebody uh comes into your
comes into your apartment at midnight
and you're a licensed gun
same thing the same thing your lights
are off
and your thing you know context like
her boyfriend had the context of hey her
ex-boyfriend might be coming in here to
do something
that might be her it might be her
ex-boyfriend at the door and i just want
to make sure this doesn't go crazy so
her boyfriend knew about the x the
police
knew about the x but think about this
they were sloppy as i said to you uh
last week when the settlement came down
12 million settlement
this is and this is like you know i kind
of want to hit myself sometimes mike i'm
i'm i'm betrayed by journalistic
training
i'm i'm betrayed by you know growing up
in the midwest and having and being
raised by sensible folk
by being raised by folk who had common
sense so i keep
trying to appeal to common sense but i
guess it doesn't matter
common sense says if you're in a job
and you are and this is a raid you
better have the t's crossed and the eyes
dotted your information better be
current you better not be
acting off of stuff that just is no
longer relevant
so the boyfriend did what he was
supposed to do oh i know her boyfriend's
a threat
the ex-boyfriend's a threat i'm gonna be
prepared the police were sloppy
in addition to be murder being murderous
they were sloppy
across the board and it cost the city of
louisville
12 million dollars and it cost brianna
taylor her life sloppiness
well let's start well let's talk about
the boyfriend for a second because
the boyfriend or even the boyfriend in
the house and even the ex-boyfriend
have been again used to justify
and even vilify brianna taylor because
we're never innocent
there's a lot of talk about innocence
until proven guilty we're never innocent
see we get we get charged tried
convicted and executed
in a matter of 8 minutes and 46 seconds
or less
as the case may be whereas we can't so
much
time and time again would deny an arrest
charges forget about even i mean it's a
victory
when it comes to justice for filling the
blank it's a victory to even get to the
point
of a trial let alone a possible
conviction
and that's whether you're a police
officer or some so-called neighborhood
watchman
or just vigilante who's got it out to go
in
and hunt the nearest black person okay
so regardless
it's always a matter of hey you know
what
the the the idea that we are naturally
violent
and out of control and need to be
policed aggressively if not
eradicated that always
plays it's always acceptable
and now what you're going to see now is
the shift
to watching the reaction because the
conversation's always about the reaction
it's never about the root cause
so now we're going to have a
conversation about the reaction in
louisville because even this week we saw
this
not only did we see this coming just
throughout our country's history we saw
it coming when they declared a state of
emergency
when they implemented a city-wide curfew
when they activated the national guard
which only gets activated when it comes
to black people responding to police
brutality
and so now there's because when people
talk about
peace what they really mean is quiet
okay they're not
certainly not talking about justice they
didn't mean quite right and so now
whatever happens and here's another
quote i'm sick and tired of going back
to is that the right
the right is the language of the unheard
but they still ain't hearing us
but they still ain't hearing us and so
now it's gonna be about oh
look at these rioters these people
protest so think about just the circle
think about the full how
the thing about how twisted that logic
is is we beget state-sponsored violence
on bodies of black and brown men and
women
if you respond in any way other than
okay no problem keep doing what you're
doing if you respond by pushing back
then it's like oh you're being violent
so now we got to come in with
militarized police
police excuse me i gotta add violence on
top of violence so endlessly yeah i got
it
yeah it's a cycle that's why so i said
i'm in
a in a place of a reflection
there's some uh quietness in here right
now
and i think part of it is i'm just going
to that next level
and and thinking of the strategy i think
protest
is extremely effective i think protest
is a part of american history
long before there was a black lives
matter uh
long before there was an mlk
and a malcolm x i mean years and years
this country everything that has
happened in this country everything
has been the result of a protest saying
looking at something and said this
should not be i'm going to push back
against it
and create something else so protest has
its way it is a very american thing
don't let anybody tell you anything
different it's a very american thing so
but maybe we need to
add another layer of strategy here and
start doing
the so-called boring work okay what i
mean what do i mean by that boring
is doing some work in the
marbled hallways and these these these
libraries and
and taking apart these laws that exist
that have existed for years and looking
at them in a 21st century context and
saying
these laws do not serve us anymore and
we've got to
tear these down this i i keep saying it
don't get caught up in the in the
political response or the political
framing of it because you know
politicians are
are are self-serving too all politicians
all of them i'm not just talking about
the republicans
democrats too this is very self-serving
they'll take
the temperature of what you're talking
about and they'll see how they can use
it to their advantage this is beyond
a political conversation this is about
the people in the streets
who are looking at something who i am
hopeful are fed up with it
and are trying to make some steps take
some make some moves
to kind of dismantle things that no
longer serve a democracy
yeah that's all i can say about it
that's all i can say about it i mean
like this is
and we knew it we knew it last we knew
it was coming we knew it was coming
right
yeah it's still you prepare for it and
you expect it
but just when you hear it it seems like
it's no matter how it's delivered it's
always delivered in a unique way just to
kind of remind you
of our of our place you know in this
society i mean we you know we talked
before the show man
i was gonna say about democracy um
whether it's the passing of ruth bader
ginsburg uh
or now the miscarriage of justice when
it comes to
brianna taylor just all the more reason
for us to march to the polls
you know uh it's it's it's now or never
you know what i mean it's just that much
more motivation as if we needed it
that much more motivation to protest uh
at the polls but what i was gonna say
everybody and you gotta everybody's
gotta be called out to everybody's gotta
be called out you gotta
you gotta look see because the easy
thing i said i was done with it but
here i am again i knew you had more
that's why i know i know i know
i know i know you i knew you had more i
know um
it's so easy mike to just have it be
far off uh hey let's just look at uh
let's look at our national politics uh
let's look at the president let's look
at the senators and you just blame them
and they're part of it they're complicit
oh no
but local politics local politics
ask those questions of local politicians
so where do you stand
like these are and i tell i tell my
students this all the time
okay i'll just give you a quick um a
student a story from the academy
so last semester i was teaching one of
the courses i was teaching
was a basic news writing and reporting
course and one of their assignments
was to get a government story and i
remember what
a couple of the students saying well you
know what if uh you know if i go to the
state house and
and you know they don't call me back or
what if they don't email me back and i
said
do you understand forget about the
golden dome of this building forget
about
the beautiful architecture and and the
important people who walk in and suits
and
and expensive uh you know expensive
clothes
this is for the people and we've lost
sight of that this is for the people
this is supposed to they are supposed to
be serving you
they're supposed to be answering your
questions they're supposed to be
answering your phone calls and your
emails it's unacceptable they're not
doing the job
if they're not answering your questions
so we've got a part in the
uh part of this and the part is ask
people where do you stand
i'm very concerned about this as a
citizen so you
you've been elected what's your what's
your position on it
yeah no i mean we waited uh over six
months and i think 191 days
for nothing um and we got more to say
about it but at least for now we're
gonna put a pin in it and before the
show started
we were trying to decide like look short
of because
talking about sports or talking about
anything else right now
feels somewhat inappropriate but short
of you know
pulling the kenny smith and just
unmicking and walking off and said we're
not doing a show today
it just didn't feel right to try to you
know transition into any other subject
matter so with that we're gonna put not
only put a penny we'll come back later
to this subject
of um you know brianna taylor uh but for
now we're gonna go ahead and take a
break
and uh and come right back and and try
to move forward with
other conversations as best we can